over the past generation tremendous
productivity growth has allowed the u.s.
dairy farms and processors to become
globally competitive however despite
this growth outdated policies that are
counterproductive to the dairy economy
remain in place such policies include
the 80 year-old Orwellian federal Milk
Marketing orders a concoction of
convoluted US pricing regulations the
selectively protectionist import
barriers that suited the old inefficient
US milk industry and lastly the recent
subsidized margin insurance scheme which
offers periodic payments designed to be
highly favorable to small inefficient
farms this program may become costly
harms lower-cost farms and adds little
to risk management these programs may
benefit some farms and processors often
the least productive but do so at the
expense of taxpayers consumers in the
broad dairy industry it is now time to
let the US milk producers and processors
embrace their global competitiveness and
innovate unencumbered by obsolete policy
approaches what do you think about US
dairy subsidy schemes let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI